there's no greater problem out there
than how do we generate clean and cheap
electricity globally because like it or
not the developing world is gonna burn
coal and natural gas hi I'm David
Frieden I'm 28 I'm a principal at eight
rivers capital and project manager for
net powers and nutrition facility net
power was founded by a company called a
Brewers capital nate ruess capital our
goal is to try and solve some of the big
world problems facing humanity with
technology in net power one of the big
problems were going after is climate
change
I believe climate change is the
challenge of our generation that there's
a lot of really interesting people doing
really great things and renewables and
solar and wind but if you look at look
at all the experts in order to limit the
worst impacts of climate change carbon
capture has to be part of the solution
what our technology does is enable
carbon capture to be economic
what's funny is I was actually I went to
Duke and studied at biomedical
engineering so I always thought I wanted
to go and be a doctor
get my PhD and doing I did tissue
engineering in college and I quickly
realized that while medical vices are
really important and really interesting
energy is just so much bigger it's just
such it impacts everything
the blend of youthful ignorance and
excitement and passion with expertise I
think that's what makes the magic out
there
I don't think that you can have either
without without making the work and I
would say that's true in any industry
not just energy but I've experienced it
directly that energy market start with
achieved not with a beat right these are
trillion-dollar markets and
trillion-dollar opportunities here and
so these are massive markets and so
people should focus on this I wish more
Millennials more young people cared a
lot about climate change cared about
carbon capture and cared about
renewables
you